el día de hoy los aliados se han puesto
de acuerdo a la práctica de tres
elementos para acercar a Ucrania más a
la otan primero un programa anterior
multisistemas para Ucrania para permitir
la transición sobre las doctrinas y
entrenamiento a los estándares de la
otan para el sector de seguridad y
defensa y para cubrir necesidades que
tiene tales como combustibles
equipos y suministros médicos segundo el
consejo de la otan y Ucrania para
consulta y toma de decisiones
en donde nos vamos a reunir como iguales
como pares y espero tener la reunión
inaugural del Consejo el día de mañana
con el presidente
tercero reafirmamos que Ucrania se va a
convertir en un miembro de la otan y nos
ponemos de acuerdo en remover los
requerimientos del plan de acción esto
hace que el proceso
os pase de dos pasos a un solo paso para
la incorporación de Ucrania también
vamos a enviarle una invitación para
unirse a la otan
cuando los aliados estén de acuerdo y
cuando se cumplan con las condiciones
Este es un paquete muy fuerte para
Ucrania y una vía Clara hacia su
membresía en la otan
los aliados también
aprobaron el plan de defensa más
completo desde el final de la Guerra
Fría Esto es para contrarrestar las dos
amenazas principales que prestamos Rusia
el terrorismo y en los planes la otan
pienso planea tener 300.000 tropas
incluyendo poderío aéreo y naval
significativo
hay que tener una base industria robusta
para la defensa entonces renovar el plan
de producción Esto va a acelerar
las adquisiciones conjuntas va a
incrementar la interoperabilidad y las
capacidades de inversión y de producción
para hacer todo esto tenemos que
invertir más en defensa
nuestros últimos estimaciones muestran
que los gastos en defensa por los
aliados europeos y Canadá se va a
incrementar en un ocho punto tres por
ciento en el 2023
este es el incremento más grande en
décadas desde el 2014
haber invertido 450
trillones de dólares adicionales en
defensa y los aliados ahora llegan o
exceden
esta marca Esperamos que esta cifrain se
incremente más significativa el
siguiente año
los aliados hoy hacen un compromiso para
invertir al menos 2% del producto
interno bruto anualmente en defensa y
hacer más de manera urgente para cumplir
con sus compromisos los líderes de la
otan
dicen que china china no es adversario y
tenemos que seguir
acercándonos a China pero
afecta nuestra seguridad china está
retando la orden nacional y se rehúsa
cuando era la guerra rusa contra Ucrania
y lo cual Amén los amenos a nosotros y
está con un rearme militar sustancial
esto es sin precedentes en tamaño en
velocidad de escala y surgió sin ninguna
transparencia los aliados están de
acuerdo en continuar trabajando juntos
para protegerse en contra de este
comportamiento de China el día de mañana
nos vamos a reunir con Los líderes de
Australia Japón Nueva Zelanda y Corea
del Sur así como la Unión Europea porque
somos más fuertes estamos más seguros
cuando estamos Unidos y con esto abro el
espacio para preguntas vamos a empezar
con Washington post ahí en el centro por
favor
gracias Por recibir mi pregunta del
Washington presidente
publicó un tweet en la mitad de la
charla que critica el lenguaje
el cual se acaba poner de acuerdo sobre
la solicitud de membresía de Ucrania me
pregunto
Cuál es su opinión cuando vio lo que le
estaba diciendo con respecto a lo cual
estaba acordando la tónico cuál sería su
mensaje para los ucranianos que están
decepcionados por Este lenguaje bueno
los aliados se pusieron de acuerdo el
día de hoy en
un mensaje positivo unificado y fuerte
para Ucrania
sobre el apoyo continuo pero también un
mensaje positivo sobre el camino tomar
para la membresía y esto incluye este
paquete de apoyo práctica para permitir
una interoperabilidad total entre las
fuerzas más y las fuerzas armadas de la
otan
es el establecimiento donde el consejo
de la otan y Ucrania y la remoción del
plan de acción de la otan Eso quiere
decir que en vez de dos pasos para
volverse miembros se les permite hacerlo
en un solo paso y también dejamos Claro
que se va a enviar la invitación cuando
se cumplan las condiciones me gustaría
agregar que adicionalmente por supuesto
los aliados también están proporcionando
apoyo militar significativo porque la
tarea más urgente en este momento es
garantizar que Ucrania
siga subsistiendo porque si no subsiste
pues no se va a discutir la membresía en
absoluto Entonces por lo tanto el apoyo
militar que los aliados han
proporcionado ya durante meses
de hecho empezó en el 2014 y desde la
invasión entre el año pasado pues se ha
incrementado este apoyo de manera
significativa
y en los últimos días los aliados
nuevos anuncios significativos Francia
anunció que va a entregar
misiles de crucero de largo alcance
Alemania acaba de anunciar un nuevo
paquete para defensas antiaéreas y
vehículos blindados y los Estados Unidos
hizo otro anuncio adicional sobre más
apoyo militar y muchos otros aliados
manifestaron su apoyo incluyendo el
establecimiento de una coalición para
proporcionar entrenamiento para los
pilotos de los f-16 entonces este este
conjunto es un mensaje contundente que
envía un mensaje positivo y unificado a
kiev vamos a ir con la agencia de
noticias de Ucrania
noticias de Ucrania Gracias por serme la
palabra una pregunta para mi colega
Podemos esperar el día de hoy un
comunicado final con respecto a Ucrania
o lo podemos esperar mañana y por favor
podría especificar Qué tipo de
condiciones
necesita
cumplir
Ucrania para iniciar el procedimiento de
admisión y recibir la invitación gracias
Ya estamos de acuerdo el comunicado ya
nos pusimos acuerdo en un paquete para
Ucrania solo hicieron nuestros líderes y
yo referí los elementos principales hace
un momento
las uniones políticas con el consejo de
Ucrania con la otan para
interoperabilidad del la remoción del
plan de acción de la otan y diferentes
cosas que los aliados están
proporcionando de manera bilateral
Incluyendo los nuevos anuncios que oímos
el día de hoy
y en los últimos días
yo
he estado en contacto regular y cercano
y los aliados Yo también están en
contacto regular cercano con los
oficiales de Ucrania
y con el presidente
y espero poder reunirme con él esta
noche y también tener la reunión
inaugural de
el consejo de otan y Ucrania el día de
mañana en donde voy a enviar el paquete
de los tres elementos
va acercando Ucrania más a la otan y
este es un paquete contundente
Hola
Andreas tu pregunta por favor
para volver a las declaraciones que
diría que dice que sería absurdo si no
se estableció un marco ni para la
invitación ni para la membresía de
Ucrania cómo le respondería a ese punto
específico y por qué los aliados no han
establecido un marco de tiempo
específico el día de hoy nos pusimos de
acuerdo en un paquete sustancial con
muchos elementos distintos que ayudan a
acercar a Ucrania más a la otan y les
ayuda
a acercarse de la membresía de la otan y
este es un apoyo muy práctico por
ejemplo la interoperabilidad y
reformas del sector defensa y la
entrepiso son unas de las condiciones
que son importantes para la membresía
Entonces esto es una ayuda práctica para
acercar a Ucrania más a la otan
y también enviamos un mensaje Atlético
muy contundente con el lenguaje sobre la
membresía incluyendo lenguaje que
ahorita está en el comunicado y desde la
invitación entonces nunca ha habido un
mensaje más contundente la tan en ningún
momento tanto cuando se trata el mensaje
político y en el camino que hay que
tomar para la membresía y el apoyo
militar y práctico de los aliados de La
otan sobre cómo garantizar una
interoperabilidad total
y si miran todos los procesos de
membresía no ha habido un momento no
había una línea de tiempo para estos
procesos siempre ha sido con base en
condiciones